the danger is a big Pharma sisters at
War a surprising message from an
unlikely Source this is the ending of
Netflix's new horror series Resident
Evil explained
since the Dawn of the Dead the zombie
apocalypse has been used by artists
across a variety of mediums to act as a
cautionary tale regarding the dangers of
an era's current path while George
Romero's movie exposed the willful
ignorance of the Reagan Era capcom's
Resident Evil released in 1996 spoke to
a society grappling with the
consequences of the greed is good 80s
and an increase in awareness of the not
always benevolent nature of big Pharma
Elizabeth wurtzel's Prozac Nation had
come out just two years prior and a
newly public company called America
Online had just left in the course of a
year from 1 million to 5 million members
the disillusionment of the 60s and 70s
had returned but in the form of a
general malaise and cynicism aided by a
boom in technology that was evolving
rapidly the malevolent entity at the
center of Resident Evil the Umbrella
Corporation brilliantly encapsulated the
era's dependence on and wariness of
profit-hungry Corporations while the
game's various Monsters made tangible
the worst case scenario fears of an
increasingly skeptical generation while
a game evolved with each of its numerous
iterations and spin-offs this thematic
core remained the same and while the
Resident Evil films get a lot wrong
about the games and have an otherwise
convoluted and confusing storyline even
they've been unwavering in keeping up
this subtext at least a little bit
Netflix is reimagining of the now
well-worn zombie yarn does this as well
but with one very important tweak you
don't need to sift through the chaotic
timeline of the Resident Evil films to
appreciate Netflix's new series the two
films that feel like the most
predominant influences on series Creator
Andrew Dobbs take have nothing
whatsoever to do with the IP or for that
matter with zombies though they're no
less horrifying for it the revelations
provided in 2021's the crime of the
century a two-part documentary detailing
Purdue pharma's role in the opioid
epidemic and 2020s the social dilemma an
expose on surveillance capitalism and
for-profit behavior modification both
Bloom large over the eight episode
series dab series and its ending in
particular directly reference the
realities laid out in these films though
the antagonist and the Resident Evil
games has always been a greedy corporate
machine invested in global domination
it's mostly maintained a kind of
faceless vagueness and allowed it to
serve more as a template than a direct
commentary Netflix's Resident Evil on
the other hand amused its Central
villain with a clear and unnervingly
recognizable specificity
Resident Evil is not a portrait of a
dystopian future but a reflection on an
increasingly dystopian present the
notorious t-virus still kicks off the
zombie apocalypse but umbrella's path to
power and domination has evolved along
with our world forget unleashing
unkillable mutants on other countries in
2022 the ability to control a population
via medications and devices upon which
its people are fully dependent is a much
more efficient Unstoppable weapon in the
social dilemma a big Tech turncoat
Tristan Harris explains the results of
pervasive Tech two billion people he
says will have Bots that they didn't
intend to have because of a designer at
Google this is happening to each and
every one of us every time we reach for
our smartphones and it's echoed directly
by paoa nunez's Evelyn Marcus who wants
to use the company's new t-virus-laced
antidepressant joy to take this real
world mind control to a whole new level
Google Zuckerberg they deliver eyeballs
umbrella
will deliver mines
despite Wesker insisting that the
t-virus elements enjoy is still too
unstable to bring the drug to Market
Evelyn demands that he make it happen
within the next six months so that she
might successfully bring the flailing
company back to life at one point a
reporter explains umbrella's past and
present as a company besieged by legal
Scandal and falling stock prices is now
trying to reinvent itself with a major
push into direct-to-consumer drugs the
allusion to both Purdue and insist
Therapeutics an out bankrupt company
responsible for fentanyl is both clear
and cunning equally clear in their
commentary or the opioid withdrawal
mirroring side effects of joy and a
zombifying effect that high doses of the
drug elicit
so we know what goes on the warning
label
the line from Evelyn is a biting
reference the big Pharma consistently
blaming the user of a drug while
ignoring their own irresponsible
marketing to that drug is blindly
apparent the fact that umbrella's latest
weapon is manipulation and controlled
through dependency rather than monstrous
Brute Force marks a major turning point
for the narrative but in addition to
this fresh Twist on the story there's an
important thematic tie-in to the series
Source material
Netflix's Resident Evil also highlights
the gaslighting tactics used by some of
today's Tech and Pharma Giants it's for
your own good umbrella insists as do our
real world adds absent pharmaceutical
companies combine this sales tactic with
the initially good intentions that spark
so many advances in Science and Tech and
you create a dynamic wherein both seller
and buyer are locked in a one-way Road
to Hell this idea is most thoroughly
shown in the last two episodes of
Resident Evil when we learned that for
all her flippant disregard of Joy users
and for all her power hungry ambition
Evelyn might genuinely believe that her
creation could change the world as she
says several times for the better
there's more than a few shades of the
tragic tale of theranos and Evelyn's
repeated use of that phrase but in
having the umbrella CEO allow her
ambition to overtake a regard for human
life and autonomy Resident Evil is once
again presenting us with a cautionary
Tale in the penultimate episode we
learned that Evelyn has been drugging
her wife with joy in order to keep her
compliant this marks the point of no
return for the wife and mother who will
later continue her Mission despite the
loss of her son
in contrast to Evelyn The Wesker of
Netflix's Resident Evil never loses his
Humanity differing wildly from the
one-dimensional villain of the games and
movies the hard-working dad with whom
were presented for the majority of the
series is not we learn in the end the
actual Albert Wesker when the original
Wesker needed a team of scientists to
help him Advance the virus he created a
handful of Wesker clones only two of
these clones survive bur to Evelyn keeps
locked up and Albert the Dad we believe
is Wesker for most of the show but they
have serious health problems as a result
of Aging instantaneously in order to
stay alive Albert creates his two
daughters Billy and Jade and uses their
blood to Stave off his symptoms it's a
simultaneously nasty and nuanced kind of
Parental need Albert does love his
daughters as evidenced by his
willingness to do anything to protect
them here again the series is
highlighting The Not So straightforward
nature of our push-pull relationship
with scientific progress yes Wesker is
using the girls but he has no choice in
the matter if he wants to live he does
however have a choice as to whether or
not he'll sacrifice himself for her this
Gap and what he can and can't control
his human in weakness versus his human
strengths Mira's society's complicated
needed for pharmaceutical breakthroughs
in the end we learned that adult Billy
has joined umbrella eventually finding a
way to control even Evelyn Jade has gone
in a different direction working for a
rebel University and studying the
behavior of the zombies that now
Encompass the planet sister is pitted
against sister as it's revealed that
Billy like her clone dad before her
needs Jade's blood in order to survive
and one of the most important final
scenes of the series we witnessed Billy
turning to Evelyn for help
if I am sick
can you help me it's not hard to see
this cause of the sickness owner of the
Cure Dynamic and the call for companies
like Facebook to fix the monster they
created unfortunately as data scientist
Kathy O'Neill points out in the social
dilemma this is a misguided ask
we are allowing the technologists to
frame this as a problem that they are
equipped to solve
that is that's a lie Evelyn and umbrella
may be able to keep Billy alive but they
do so at the cost of her very Humanity
in the end Billy's decisions rely on the
corporation leads to her willingness to
shoot her sister in the stomach and
kidnap her niece to mind for blood as
Albert struggles to reject Evelyn's
control and the build-up to the outbreak
she reminds him that willpower has
nothing to do with his current situation
you need your medicine she says about an
hour maybe less
pain will become unbearable and you'll
give in
later as he lies dying on the floor
begging his daughters for forgiveness
Evelyn leans over him and places a
syringe of Jade's blood in his hand it's
a heartbreaking scene and one that
directly reflects the Dynamics between
an addict their family and their
supplier despite the gutting symbolism
of Albert's final moments before he
sacrifices himself to free his daughters
the series eventually leaves us with
some semblance of Hope
when adult Jade unleashes a
mountain-sized mutated crocodile on
umbrella's base camp it's not simply a
reptilian display of gamer fan service
the confrontation of past and future of
Nature and technology and of history and
progress are all brought to the
foreground in the series's final moments
the fact that umbrella's technology is
able to tear at the body of a creature
that predates our existence is of
obvious symbolic importance what's more
Jade aligning herself with the
university aka the preserver of the past
is meant to stand in direct contrast to
her sister's alignment with umbrella in
their final exchange Billy literally
says
I'm the future
the series stops short of implying that
the past is Holy Superior yes this
future is heartless Bleak infected and
driven by a manufactured dependence on a
malevolent Corporation yes we got here
by allowing our complex need for
Progress to make us reliant on such a
corporation but this doesn't mean
science and progress are in and of
themselves a bad thing the crocodile
doesn't attack Jade's daughter and
though we've yet to learn why it's
implied that Jade used some form of
science or technology to protect her
offspring it's a series finale that
leaves us with more questions and
answers we don't know if Jade survives
we don't know if Billy will harm her own
niece though it certainly looks that way
we don't know what's special about
Jade's daughter and we don't know much
about Billy's plans for umbrella we also
don't know what will become of Evelyn
the University or the world's remaining
humans thematically speaking however the
series finale ends on a fairly
conclusive note one that simultaneously
chilling and motivating by setting the
onset to the Apocalypse in our current
year and by focusing on two very real
very powerful yet complicated threats to
our society Resident Evil gives us the
most terrifying Apocalypse of the entire
IP this is happening now it says we
carry this threat this loss of
Independence through dependence around
in our pockets charge it and feed it and
feed off of it even as it feeds off us
even as it feeds more specifically off
our brains nevertheless beneath the Doom
and Gloom of the series finale there's
some hope to be gleaned from Bert's
Guile's speech to a young and still
mostly human Billy no one's really okay
we're all just doing our best
in a world where it's way too easy to do
your worst in the end this most recent
installment of Resident Evil simply
reminds us that while corporations
aren't people people still are at least
for now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
thank you